なんで野球したいの掲載わけですね今日は外したちょっと
正木取締役です
コンタクトレンズをつけようと思いますメイン悪いわけじゃないんですけどちょっと
悪くてメガネは今まで2個あったんですけど全部なくしちゃってたと言ってコンタクト
つけるの強いんでまでつけなかったんですけど老けてみようかと思います今回は
コンタクトをつけてみる動画ですつけたことあるなぁ闇悪い部屋いいけどメガネェ
今の今あるラガー
ドキドキはコンタクトレンズをつける練習をしたいと思います2年とつけてもなんか
微妙なんで
カラコンを買いましたパーフェクトシリーズ10枚入
[音楽]
わかんないけどね全然違った monday って書いちゃった
ちょっとは強い普通にやばいだってみえる方に異物を入れるでしょ
アカンでしょ普通に入って色がでアカンでしょかけてダイマーヶ月いけない
色柄枚コレットですうわぁや1は
っとくっつけてるっていうし結構あの人たちはぞ
こういう神経でれているのかっていう動画3たかったあー頭です前期型すんだよ
ani 僕の2組はこんな感じです
これ全部費や別邸に+んだってえっ摘んでいっきって行ってください
こいつれってこと
a 6グラム左手の中指で上の瞼引き上げ
中指右手の中指で下のまぶたは引き下げますでここに今この地になってるねばならぬの
人差し指でつけるってこと
結構入れてああああああ
これだぜメンターが占うと言ったら手術でしょかいうのが絶対言われて終わった救急の
準備だそれじゃあ
を知っ
バーベぴょんっ
フィギュア
ビデオはぁ落ちらー
義弟の人差し指なぜなるほどその上に打ち込むと講師と本当に出るも知らないよね
ヘッダー
ほんと怖いからでいきますいきますよああ
picture 気楽金でドラ
母
うーん青学大いる川沿繰り入れますよ
いい
ルってくれこれをしっかりグッズと言った方がいいよ
これどう
ウソッキー fa パブー2
えっ
どうぞよとしないん
どじゃないうねちゃうん
これに痛くないの
これもなんか汚いが使えないんだめっちゃ落としちゃったんだけどめっちゃ混みつい
てる心
ダメなら入れますまた来たのだできる
ほんと女じゃない腰痛っていうの頃よねこれホント難しいよいくぜ
ています
どーこーなっているもっと真ん中ホットこっちよりボルト上
しっかり入れないといけばどう
感じ
バーンも来やがったなんでこうなっちゃう思ったりしなきゃいけない無地でこれにて
くれたらいいねこれちゃうカメラ見ながら本気であるわ
ん
惜しいなぁ
いけそうだったね今ます切れては1回んだちょっと一人じゃ無理なんで真っ先に出て
もらえますさあ来い
ガーッとろーっ
あっはは
はなさんのきたパターンた8頭
このぬベッドずていいのんと子だか
を
出来た出来たなぁ
すごい5つけたらこんな感じの目になりました
9いいねはいというわけで無事着いたんですけど痛いんだとめちゃくちゃ難しいですよ
ねってが今も痛いんですよほらも涙が止まんない水沢て
れて撮るのを待って撮るの難しくないこれまた人ってえそうでしょ
ああああっ言う月にっていう
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
これなーほんとボイよよかったって言うけどや向かったブナ本当にはこれ一本は急いで
不振でたよ
me
あっひっ